vamos ahora parametrizar la superficie
que tenemos aquí y luego veremos cómo
calcular de ese para que así podamos
hacer más cuentas sobre esta integral de
superficie que tenemos del lado derecho
que era nuestro primer objetivo de esta
de esta lista de vídeos entonces para
empezar a parametrizar lo simplemente
pues vamos a ir definiendo una función
digamos r que depende de dos parámetros
pero si nos damos cuenta aquí ya estan
esos dos parámetros ya que la superficie
es la gráfica de la función de z verdad
entonces simplemente los parámetros
serán esas dos variables de las cuales
depende nuestra función z
y decimos primero que pues si tenemos un
punto digamos amarillo aquí en la región
r ok entonces ya tenemos x es decir ya
tenemos localizado un punto x de x aquí
en la región r y ese punto simplemente
lo subimos con z entonces en la
dirección
simplemente tenemos a x vamos a sumar en
la dirección j pues ayer ok y en la
dirección z que es hacia arriba perdón
en la dirección del vector k es
simplemente la función zeta que depende
de x y correcto entonces ya que tenemos
esta función pues simplemente hay que
restringir en donde estamos moviendo los
parámetros y en este caso los parámetros
se encuentran sobre ere es decir x que
está en nuestra región r porque si
tenemos un punto fuera de la región pues
ya no estamos considerando ese pedazo de
la superficie si es que existe entonces
con esto estamos ya completando la
parametrización y ya estamos listos para
calcular quién es de ese vamos a
movernos un poquito hacia abajo y
entonces de ese recordemos que de ese
simplemente es el producto cruz de
nuestros vectores que resultan de ser
las derivadas parciales de nuestra
función r
y que simplemente son los cambios
direccionales en al mover nuestros
parámetros correcto entonces
ya con esto dicho también tenemos que
multiplicar por una diferencial de área
correcto
en otros términos si lo escribimos
matemáticamente estamos diciendo que
vamos a tener que hacer el producto cruz
de nuestros vectores direccionales
digamos rx cruz r y aja que son las
derivadas parciales ya esto hay que
multiplicarlo por los cambios los
cambios que hay tanto en la dirección x
como en la dirección ya que si no
queremos volvernos medio engorrosos con
la anotación simplemente lo podemos
poner como una diferencial de área
entonces esto es de s
vamos a vamos a ver ahora que este
producto cruce es decir nuestro vector
normal a la superficie que es así es
como se cae se calcula está realmente en
la dirección que queremos porque si
recordamos y si queremos atravesar esta
está esta curva que es la frontera de
nuestra superficie pues tenemos que
garantizar que el producto
y apunta siempre o más bien que si vamos
recorriendo en este sentido siempre
tengamos del lado izquierdo la
superficie ok y eso implicaría que
nuestro producto cruzó el vector normal
apunta hacia arriba muy bien es decir es
como si colocamos nuestra cabeza en
dirección del vector
normal entonces vamos a ver cómo nos
movemos como es r x la derivada de r
respecto de x por ejemplo si estábamos
en este punto al movernos en la
dirección x pues simplemente es movernos
de esta forma ok y si nos movemos en la
dirección o en la dirección del vector j
es movernos en esta dirección por lo
tanto vamos a recordar cómo es la regla
de la mano derecha simplemente en la
dirección del primer vector ponemos
nuestro dedo índice ok en la dirección
del segundo vector ponemos nuestro dedo
digamos en medio y realmente no nos
importa qué pasa con los otros dedos no
pueden estar así digamos ok y ya una vez
hecho esto pues si ustedes colocan sus
dedos de esa forma en la dirección donde
queda el pulgar es a donde apunta el
vector normal entonces esto quedaría más
o menos
de esta forma ok y entonces nuestro
vector normal si apunta en esta
dirección entonces estamos muy bien
estamos parametrizado muy bien de hecho
estamos calculando muy bien el producto
cruz apunta justo de la de la forma en
que queremos si invirtiéramos el orden
pues apuntaría hacia abajo pero bueno
con esto basta y ahora sí vamos a
calcular esto vamos a ver quiénes rx
vamos a bajar un poquito más
quienes ere x cruz
r
quién es esto bueno pues esto lo podemos
calcular como el determinante de una
matriz bueno no es una matriz como tal
sino como técnicamente al menos es eso
donde ponemos a los vectores canónicos y
el vector canónico j y el vector
canónico k que apuntan en las
direcciones horizontal vertical y hacia
digamos de altura ok
y saca y aquí va a ir el vector rx la
derivada de r respecto de x pero quién
es ese es derivar cada una de las
entradas respecto de x entonces al
derivar la primera nos queda 1 al
derivar la segunda nos queda 0 porque
sólo está ahí y al derivar la tercera
nos queda la derivada parcial de 7
respecto de x correcto entonces esto
estamos suponiendo entonces que la
función zeta es es derivable al menos en
ese punto entonces vamos ahora a
calcular el vector r
es decir la derivada de r respecto de
ella y al derivar la primera entrada
respecto de llenos de a 0 al derivar la
segunda nos queda uno y al derivar la
tercera nos queda detalle es decir la
derivada de zeta
respecto de y vamos a calcular esto
entonces nos tomamos nuestro primer
elemento que es
que multiplica
al quitar la columna y el renglón de iu
pues nos queda el determinante de esta
sub matriz que simplemente es menos zeta
x correcto luego nos vamos con él con el
segundo elemento y le cambiamos el signo
esto va a multiplicar al quitar renglón
y columna nos queda el determinante de
una sub matriz que simplemente es
detalle
correcto es la derivada de z respecto de
iu y ahora simplemente nos tomamos
nuestro vector k
nuestro vector k quitamos su renglón y
su columna y nos que el determinante de
esta sub matriz que es 1 entonces así es
simplemente como se queda
no voy a escribirlo un poquito más
agradable esto simplemente será menos se
está sub x es decir la derivada de 7
respecto de x por y menos la derivada de
zeta respecto de y por jota más acá